[Music]
well when you're in a medical emergency
EMTs are usually the first ones to
respond but you may not realize how much
they're getting paid to keep you alive
Victoria Saha joins us in studio tonight
with how having a passion for the job
simply is not enough for some of them
EMTs are leaving their jobs for higher
wages in other Industries data from the
U.S Bureau of Labor Statistics shows
nearly one-third of EMTs quit in 2021
which could mean a difference of life or
death when you need to get to a hospital
it's a sound that doesn't ever mean
something good but the job those inside
the ambulance are doing means everything
to a patient I saw uh one October and it
broke my heart so once I was able to
afford it I took the Mt class Sabrina
Morris finds passion in helping people
at some of the worst times in their life
it's just the pay is so so low Morris
says when she first started working with
Community Ambulance a little over a year
ago she was making ten dollars an hour
it's a lot of work and it's a lot of
knowledge and it's a lot of risk for not
a lot of pay the mom of two says her pay
did increase to 1321 but it's nowhere
near the national median average pay for
EMTs which is 1705 in a whole year I
make about before taxes 25 000 a year if
I went back to my Walmart job they're
paying 16 to start
and that's just moving boxes to help
make ends meet Morris became a surrogate
all while working full-time as an EMT we
get worked pretty hard if we could pay
all of our employees more even more we
would Glenn Simpson the senior director
with Community Ambulance says a
reimbursement from insurance is a big
reason for Less pay what a lot of people
don't realize is our collection rate on
all ambulance bills across the board is
less than 35 percent Simpson says they
have to respond to every call but if
they respond to a medical call and use
their own equipment only to have the
patient refuse transfer they aren't paid
for their services
Community has switched over to having
three work days for employees I also
spoke with AMR they tell me they
increase their pay for EMTs to just over
fourteen dollars an hour Victoria Saha
eight news now